hola buenas tardes pues yo me encuentro
como usted lo dice en el centro de
convenciones de corferias este es el
puesto de votación más grande en
colombia y hace parte de los doce mil
centros de votación que con en total
tienen un total de 112 mil de mesas
desplegadas por todo el país hay una
custodia tanto policial como del
ejército en todo el país es de 300 mil
uniformados según ha dicho el ministro
de defensa diego molano quien también ha
entregado un parte de relativa
normalidad el en su cuenta de 'twitter'
ha dicho que ha habido dos explosiones
con artefactos en municipios alejados
municipios de zonas rurales del país que
han dejado por el momento un soldado
herido es la única del único episodio de
violencia que se ha registrado por el
momento aquí en el país en esta jornada
electoral los candidatos también ya
ejercieron su derecho al voto en el
transcurso de la mañana lo hizo también
el presidente de la república saliente e
iván en duke márquez y nosotros hablamos
también con algunas de las personas que
se han acercado a uno de los principales
puntos de votación del país la
importancia de venir a votar el día de
hoy es cambiar este gobierno que lleva
más de 20 años siempre
nos están mandando los mismos entonces
la idea de votar es cambiar cambiar este
país que es muy bueno tiene muchos
recursos tiene muchas cosas buenas tiene
gente buena entonces necesitamos un
cambio total para para nuestros
gobernantes en el día de hoy en estas
votaciones que se transparente que se
vacíe que deja a un lado su persona como
tal y se llene del país de todas las
necesidades del país de yo pienso en
estas elecciones como mi deseo
personalmente de echar raíces a la vida
a la paz a la dignidad a todo eso que
nos han quitado por tanto tiempo y que
nos hace falta daniela y además ya
empezó la votación en el exterior antes
de este domingo cuéntenos si se conocen
resultados preliminares
bueno de los 38 8 millones de ciudadanos
habilitados para votar en estas
elecciones presidenciales de colombia en
2022 tenemos 2 972 mil ciudadanos
habilitados para votar en los diferentes
puntos en el exterior y que han venido
votando a lo largo de la última semana
lo que conocemos por ahora es que se han
depositado en total 168 mil votos por
parte de estas personas esto nos daría
hasta este momento una abstención de un
80 por ciento y es que este es un país
con una índice de abstención bastante
alto mire el 47 por ciento en la más
reciente elección presidencial en 2018
también hay que decir que se espera que
los resultados o más bien las urnas se
cerrarán a las 4 de la tarde -hora
local- y que los resultados por parte
del registrador nacional del estado
civil se den a conocer a partir de las 7
u 8 de la noche cuando determine el
preconteo que es de todas maneras un
conteo inicial y que eso no es un
escrutinio final y que tuvo bastantes
problemas en la pasada en los pasados
comicios legislativos del 13 de marzo